what is up believe nation welcome to
another entrepreneur AMA we are 61 days
away from my workshop in September
teaching people how to make money as a
thought leader from your ideas how to
turn what's in here this genius into a
business whether it's writing books
creating content doing brand deals
I want to unload all the content I got
in here and help you move forward so I'm
super pumped about that every Thursday I
go live on YouTube I answer your
questions sometimes I have a guest on
board and sometimes it's just me and so
welcome everybody as you come in live if
you want to ask me a question put it in
the chat tag me it's gonna be a lot
easier for me to see and let's get
started first one Salima writes in how
do you deal with overwhelm and get
unstuck so for me I think it really
comes down to self awareness I think as
an entrepreneur you will you will easily
feel more and more stuck as you grow and
get more success whatever is on your
to-do list we love we love an ideas list
right that's what we're great at we're
great at coming up with ideas your ideas
list will only get bigger your your
to-do list will only get bigger and more
important as you build your business as
you get older as you have more
commitments to family and you get
married and all this other stuff right
as you build a team like your your
idealist and to-do list is just gonna
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger bigger so what I like to do is I
find that for me planning my weeks out
and day by day really helps so for
example every Thursday is my
public-facing day I'm according this on
a Thursday I just did interviews earlier
today I've got more interviews and
podcasts coming up later on today and I
like having my extrovert day I like
having my public-facing day and any
meeting that I have you know unless it's
some big meeting unless unless Oprah's
calling I try to jam it into a Thursday
and then so each day I do different
things and what I find really really
helps is when I look at my mission of
what I'm trying to do right that's where
I start what is your mission right I
want it I want to solve the world's
biggest problem what's the best way for
me to do it what is the best way for me
to accomplish this mission
part of it is creating YouTube content
right part of that is mentoring the
people on my team part of that is is
doing interviews and being a face part
of that is working on other projects
that I'm working on and so I like being
with a chunk my days down according to
the priorities that I list if you have
that big to-do list the biggest
challenge people have is focusing it's
coming up with a priority list because
if you have a hundred things to do it's
easy to look at that list say this is
crazy I'm never gonna get this stuff
done and then end up doing zero you do
nothing so that's not the path right
look at the list and see what is gonna
help you accomplish your mission what
activities will help you the most
move the ball as far forward as possible
and I think when people get really stuck
is you don't know what your mission is
you don't know what your purpose is you
don't know what you're trying to go off
and accomplish and so if you don't know
your mission it's really hard to pick
the tasks that are best for you but when
you do you run everything through that
filter so as an example I was on are any
of you earlier today and the woman asked
me are you gonna make a movie and then
she asked me are you going to make a
little workbook because other people had
these little workbooks I said you know
for now I don't have a son of my radar
I'm open to it but it's not a priority
right now I don't see it as being the
best way to further my mission right now
it may be in three months I'm not close
to the idea what I'm focusing so much
time on now is my 254 series the
confidence 254 and explaining to others
where every morning for the next 254
mornings it's in your video for free 30
seconds to 5 minutes long and help you
build confidence I'm so pumped I think
it's gonna I think it's gonna help so
many people that that's where I really
want to focus and I see that expanding
to having a hundred different to fifty
fours and maybe beyond so that's gonna
take a lot of energy effort and time and
so I have to weigh that against the
suggestion of do I want to have a movie
the suggestion of do I want to have a
workbook or not right I have to weigh
those things and whatever is gonna help
my mission move forward better that's
what I'm gonna go off and do it's not
that one idea is better than the other
sure maybe a movie is the thing that
that is a great idea just for now I
don't see that as being the best
for me and so when you have our super
clear mission then you can look at all
your to do's and you can put them in
your calendar in a way that makes sense
and if you ever feel yourself falling
behind you feel yourself struggling if
you yourself not getting the stuff done
that you need to get done then you don't
have the right priorities and whenever
I'm often I know something needs to
change my calendar so example when I
started working with TBS when I started
working with Lily
Lulu's in the chat hey Lily I didn't
have the time I didn't just have a free
day open in my schedule to say hey this
is great let's go work with Alex and
Lily I'm so bored with my life I have
all this free time listen listen give it
to these people
now I was already busy before that but
to take on those two relationships I now
had to remove something else from my
list and that's okay that furthers my
mission in what I want to do I see the
opportunity there compared to what I was
doing and so I cut some things and do
these other things and so always having
the mission focus and then being willing
to cut the things that are no longer
serving you've been willing to adopt
adapt change maybe having a movie in
three months will be the best thing for
me ever and if I feel that way I will I
will shift everything around just to
make that happen
five years ago I never said I wanted to
write a book I said I I said I didn't
want to write a book I would never write
a book and now I've got two books what
changed what change was I felt like for
your one word the concept of the book
work fast to help my mission to help
people get the message I thought the
book format worked better in this case
than videos for the top ten rules I like
the idea of people having a physical
copy that everyday you can read one page
in the book I like that idea I use it
myself
and so again the book format worked best
and so just because I said that I would
never do a book five years ago it
doesn't mean that I'm super closed off
to it I would never do it so I've
changed my language a little bit so when
somebody says they're gonna do a movie
I'm gonna do a little booklet it's just
not a priority right now so know your
mission and then figure out your
priorities and being willing to be
flexible on how you accomplish your
mission but the mission is where you
stay super stubborn about
thank you for the question Frank Evan
recommended a speaker whose lesson is
don't quit or perseverance when should
you quit so so I think people should
quit all the time I think when you don't
quit is when you love the thing I think
if you don't love the thing then you
should quit immediately and I think
people fall into the wrong camps on
these things I think there's so many
people who are in a business that they
hate but because somebody said don't
quit don't quit they'll quit then they
stay in it and it could be a business
could be a relationship like get out
ASAP you don't like it here
right you have to enjoy the work you
have to enjoy the process if you do not
enjoy the work and the process you need
to be out immediately if you enjoy the
work in the process but you're not
getting results yet that's when you
don't quit that's we need to keep going
let's hear you continue to hone your
craft you know if you love making videos
but nobody's watching them yet you're
not
try not to be attached to the end result
of how many views you're getting how
many subscribers you're getting it's am
i enjoying the process of making videos
because if you enjoy the process of
making videos if you like the idea of
you creating content that will serve
potential millions of people then you
just need to keep going to get better
like you're not getting results yet
because you're not good enough but with
practice by keeping going you will get
better right and so even this morning I
started up a basketball routine again I
used to play basketball when I was
younger I've been playing about 20 years
and decide you know what morning routine
I'm gonna I'm gonna put some basketball
in there and I went two days ago and I
showed up on the court I missed my first
15 shots it's pretty embarrassing my
shoes fell apart on me they're old shoes
I guess and the glue came unstuck and I
had to I had to I had to stop after like
15 minutes I went back today I lasted
just over 20 minutes it's it's insanely
hot I don't have my endurance up yet I
missed fewer shots and and and I had to
leave over 20 minutes now fast forward
like in three months six months a year
whatever I'll be able to go I'll be able
to go an hour right now I'll be draining
more shots and I am right now I enjoy
the game I enjoy the process of getting
there and taking the shots and
practicing my jumper
like it it's fun even though the results
suck even though if anybody you know was
clocking my shooting percentage or if I
was doing one-on-one with somebody I
would get destroyed even those you know
kids playing around me and and watching
me throw bricks up brick after brick
after brick it doesn't matter because I
like the process and I will get better
at it if I keep doing it and so that's
the key if you were doing basketball
just because somebody said you need to
work out and you need to get healthy
well there's a lot of ways to work out
and get healthy picking bacteria that
you love doing and if you love doing it
but you suck at it you can improve your
skills at almost anything with just
enough practice so you quit when you
don't like it and a lot of people start
a business that they never liked in the
first place so you should quit before
you even start but if you love the thing
and you're not getting results yet then
that's when you need to keep going I
think a lot of people talk about quit
and don't quit I just wanted to add that
little bit of context in there because
like all advice it's contextual it's
very rare to have like black and white
advice on something
except belief always believe in yourself
black and white so I think people should
quit if you're just chasing results you
do enjoy in the process what else
what is it court what is your current
morning daily and weekly routine Zachary
so morning I wake up about seven ish
right now so my routine has shifted up a
little bit I wake up at seven I I make a
quick video on Instagram for me I
consume content like reading a page from
the book but I get fired up when I share
it so consuming isn't enough for me I
need to share I need to contribute even
if it's only a 15-second video so if
anybody follows me on Instagram snapchat
even Twitter you'll see my 15-second
black-and-white kind of rant or
motivational message of the morning I do
that to contribute but I also do that to
fire myself up then I go to shoot some
hoops and then I go to Whole Foods pick
up a salad pick up a kombucha and come
back home and then I start working
Monday is TDs day and Lilly day so it's
my mentoring day basically I don't work
here we're from TDI
in the entire day is basically dedicated
to helping the people grow on my team
tuesdays youtube day i'm reviewing the
videos i'm recording the videos i am
looking at my analytics i'm i'm talking
strategy for the channel wednesday is
project day and that varies each
wednesday so for example yesterday was I
was doing my once a month filming for
some of the in special videos on my
channel so and spresso in seven ways I
tried to film once a month when you see
them at TDS that's what I'm doing
Wednesday could also be working my 254
confident series it could be working on
my ebook that we just saw it launched it
could be hiring somebody new for the
team it could be designing a new t-shirt
like whatever project that I want to I
want to explore I get to do it on a
Wednesday as my own thing my own project
whatever I'm feeling passionate about
Thursday is my public facing day so this
Hangouts interviews podcasts radio shows
whatever basically the entire day lined
up with interviews and spreading my
message and the Friday is CEO day so
their ongoing projects and I've
commitments to reviewing my social media
accounts what's working what's not
working planning the week ahead all the
kind of CEO work that I have to do to
build the business Saturday is day off
with the family
so nothing invades my Saturday unless
unless I've talked about with Nina
even even family like chores and admin
we don't do that on Saturday Saturday
usually involves me picking something
for us to do in the city almost always a
new food option my wife is a big foodie
he wants to taste new food so that's my
job
I plan almost pretty much every Saturday
as a surprise for Nina so I planned the
we I planned the weekend and we might go
for hiking trip Michael Street festival
always try some new food might watch a
movie at night whatever it is and then
Sunday is more family admin day
you know cleanup chores shopping you
know go see Nina's family what el
whatever that kind of stuff I like it
because it's designed around my
personality so I like missing things
in-between
I like filming on a Tuesday and look
going deep on my YouTube channel and
then not seeing it again till next
Tuesday I like missing it I like going
live on Thursday and doing all these
interviews and podcasts and then I don't
do anything until next Thursday so like
I like missing it in between and I also
have a really hard time switching
between tasks so going from speaking
like this to then making you know
working on my book and then coming back
to in their interview that the task
switching for me is huge and so I become
massively unproductive which is why I
like doing everything of the same kind
of idea on on one day a week so that's
my that's my current morning daily and
weekly routine next we LaVon I'm
building a company I have zero passion
about stop it is huge potential but I'm
not too excited about it but I can't
make serious money but it can make
serious my name and partner loves it but
I don't look at the money listen if
you're doing something that's that's
only for money you can win in the short
term you just it'll eat at your soul and
you will never win long term you can go
rob somebody and you will make money in
the short term right it'll eat at your
soul and you won't win long-term now
that's unethical but if you see an
opportunity quickly in Instagram TV
because nobody's doing it yet and
there's not between for you to go and
win there you might have a little bit of
success early on before people jump in
on it you're just fighting the arbitrage
game but as it gets more sophisticated
you will lose like if you are not
passionate about it the people who will
come into it will love it and they will
crush you that's in any industry and -
you will feel more and more like you're
just selling your soul and you won't be
happy you might make a little bit of
short-term money but you won't be happy
where if you can build something from
the foundation up that the work itself
gives you joy and you're providing value
then it becomes this unstoppable force
then you're happy forever
like I've already won I'm happy forever
no matter how much money I end up making
or how many people end up reaching I get
to do work every single day that I love
doing I get to help entrepreneurs it it
fires me up it fires me up guys and it
may it may take you a while to build
that base
you know me building my YouTube channel
wasn't overnight it was it was you know
four years of serious work of everyday
posting you know three videos a day but
that's it like once you do once you find
the thing that you love doing and you
start being able to make just enough to
survive you've won you've won the whole
game that's it and so people are making
these short-term decisions and they end
up never being happy so stop it new
LaVon you're genius you've got talent
man stop hanging on people who only
value money you will lose the people on
top of every single game they care about
money but it's not number one when you
make your number one you lose all right
what else we got Richard loving this guy
I would love to meet you Evan so two
options one my workshop in September
it's coming up is for 10 to 15 people
otherwise if you are on any of my email
lists when I travel I like going and
meeting up with fans so I just came back
from Boston on the weekend with Nina and
my film crew actually too and I email
everybody who's from Boston who is on my
list so hey I'm coming to Boston we're
doing a free Meetup who wants to who
wants a chat and we always have a ton of
fun and we're gonna be doing some more
travel coming up meeting some some
cities we'll make an announcement at
some point and working on something
special but for anybody who wants to
meet up if you're on the newsletter list
that's that's the best part apart from
coming to Toronto for the workshop in
September what else what else what else
watching from Orange County Florida
awesome teach thirteen do you think pain
makes you more mature and strong I think
I think I think pain I think pain is the
ultimate answer like I think your
purpose comes from your pain I think it
forces you to grow up I think it does
make you strong I think it also
ultimately leads to your happiness to be
honest I think people are built to serve
and I think when you figure out what
pain and struggle that you went through
a lot of times we just try to avoid that
and we never want to go back there we
want to try to avoid the pain but if you
die back into the pain then I think
that's where ultimately you
find happiness not from reliving your
own pain but by then figuring out what
you did to overcome it or manage it and
then serving others who are facing it
right now I just think that's human
nature when you have been through
something that is massively painful for
you you want to make the road easier for
the people who are coming after you and
so I love entrepreneurs yes because
we're gonna solve all the world's major
problems and yes because you know we're
doing great for the world but my purpose
comes from my pain which is because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur
that I just don't want people to suffer
the same way that I did and even today
even though you know got multiple
businesses and and have had success I
still resonate and relate more to the
people who are just getting by you know
I still remember not being able to
afford a full meal at McDonald's right
and so like that's the world that I live
in I still had a hard time even even
flying business class you know it's it's
it's hard you know when I bought when I
bought my car it was it was hard it's
like even these feelings are self worth
because I'm still locked into like pure
startup mentality the people that I
relate to that massive pain and it's
great because it created all this like
if I didn't go through that pain I'm
certain my business I would not be doing
this right now and this is ultimately
what gives me my greatest satisfaction
and what a disservice you know you guys
wouldn't have all these videos as well
and so I think pain is great you may not
think about it at the time or in the
moment but I think pain is great I think
even showcasing your pain because your
journey through the pain is interesting
it's a constant reminder to myself this
morning I filmed an IG story of me
quitting after 20 minutes of playing
basketball because it was too hot it was
like I'm done like I can't keep going
that's it 20 minutes tomorrow I'll come
back and I'll try to do better you know
I wish if somebody was with me I would
have them fill me missing the 15 shots
in a row throwing up bricks airballs
cons
we won just a release just to get rid of
the judgment like you people are so
afraid to fail publicly that the way
through is to fail publicly more and not
accept that judgment and to to show the
journey and the struggle I filmed one
yesterday to when I was doing my in
specials I've been challenged to film a
new format for my in special videos and
it just takes me way too long I'm not
used to taking that long to film a video
anymore and and so I was I was filming
my struggle not just the aftermath not
just yeah I was hard I struggled and I'm
now I got it and this is amazing it's
like no like I'm struggling right now
and learning to recognize that my
document in the struggle in the paint is
inspiration when you document the
struggle in the pain that you're going
through you don't have the answers yet
don't pretend to be an expert on
something if you're not but you
documenting the journey of you going
through to try to solve that problem is
inspiration to other people that's what
I got what else
whoa tons of questions this thing just
refreshed okay nobody tagging hoot Agnes
go to tag one de oh I'm passionate about
it but how to move on even you sometimes
feel like quitting I am passionate about
it is there more context here how to
keep moving forward if you don't feel
like it okay so if you are passionate
about it then you need to find a way you
need to find a way you need to find a
way you need to find a way you need to
find a way you know I think it's a
combination of things I don't think
people wake up feeling like super
passionate excited I don't wake up every
day like you know I don't wake up like
that I wake up I'm tired I was up late
last night til you know - and I woke up
at 7:00 so that's that's less sleep than
I'd like to have I gotta get up and go
do my basketball do my quotes I think I
think having a routine that serves you
so for me reading a page in the book
making a 15-second video for Instagram
that gets me fired up even from super
tired
then going to do an activity I enjoy
like basketball that that routine sets
me up for success understanding the
thing that that gets you fired up and
put that
to your morning routine I think music is
an easy way to ship things as well put
on songs that you love that make you
move that make you want to bounce and
always remembering the mission that
you're on I think I think about it as
Big Y little Y the Big Y is the mission
the big picture what you're trying to
accomplish what you're trying to do and
the little y is you may not be always
thinking you can accomplish that big
thing but you know you can help one
person and whether you made a video or
whether you put something up on IG or
whether you helped the friend that was
something know that know that you are
valuable know that when you spend time
on something it makes an impact on
people even if it's just one person and
knowing that you help one person means
you can help a million people and so a
big light a little Y you've got to find
a way to keep going if you don't like it
it's if you don't like the work as
opposed to feel like it right you don't
like the work then stop but if you love
the work and you just don't feel you
have the energy then it comes down to
the other things right
morning routine environment right figure
what you're so afraid of and just go do
it
like you're afraid of failing in front
of somebody else then go fail publicly
just to release it I think it's super
important and if you're lacking
confidence get to 254 confidence series
right or build your own to 54 series
right like my channel really is a 250
for believe series anytime you need more
believe come to the channel you'll find
a video whether you get your inspiration
for something else books podcasts and
then start your day with that build your
own to 54 series and why 254 because it
takes 18 to 254 days for a new habit to
set so if you do this you do something
for 254 days
the habit will be entrenched for some
people as little as 18 the average is 66
and the worst case Center is 254 so why
I created that program was I'm with you
every step of the way you have no
excuses you sit there and watch a video
next Zack
Claire how do you say motivated during
tough times of failures lots of lots of
similar questions I am I embrace it like
the tough times and the failures are the
best it means you're doing something
important I try to look at it and not
get overwhelmed by it and say this is
this is my chance like you will if you
are doing something that is at the edge
of your comfort zone that's where you're
gonna be happy if you were doing
something that you never fail at it
means you're playing your life too
simple too easy like if you get up and
you never fail and you never get down
you are not living a human life like you
will hate your life the people think
about it all you did is every day you
wake up and you knew exactly what was
gonna happen that day and then and then
that happened you would hate your life
the challenge that growth the excitement
right you're watching World Cup you
don't know who's gonna win if you know
the end of it if you know the results
you're not gonna watch it the struggle
the failure is what makes the winning so
exciting and when you're losing it's
still the best when I'm missing my 15
shots in a row it's the best because
when I hit it that's 16 shots like I got
one right or just went to the court and
just shot and they're all going in it's
gonna be boring won't be funny anymore
so I try to adopt that mindset when I'm
losing when it's not working out I
naturally go to that place where like
this is amazing this frustration anytime
you've accomplished anything great it's
coming the other side of frustration you
may not have the answer yet and it's
it's sometimes hard to see that's good
is coming when you're in frustration
mode but when you are frustrated that's
when something great is about to happen
to you when when when things are
overwhelming when things you know are
all against you like that's when
something great is about to happen
because it'll force you to do something
the enemy of good or the enemy of great
is good right if you're just good you're
good you're good good life is good you
don't force yourself to do anything but
when it sucks
when you're really frustrated with
something that's what forces you to go
off and take some action and so what
I've been trying to do recently is try
to document that so when I'm filming and
I'm frustrated I should try to share it
when I'm playing basketball and I'm
frustrated try to share it not just show
the end result afterwards about making a
success because there's lots of these
many frustrations and failures on a
daily basis and so know that when you
are frustrated or angry not having
success that's the best because you're
about to make a huge breakthrough okay
ah let's do let's see a cache I'd like
to learn something from failures but I'm
scared of being insolvent and having
zero bank balance great so don't spend
money don't spend money till you're
making money I hate spending money
telling making money there's always a
way to get started on a smaller scale
whatever your big dream your big
ambition your big goal is chunk it down
figure out what the next first step is
and go do that you do not need money you
probably don't even need anybody else to
help you any any of their resources yet
but you might so you can go ask for help
but but spending money on an idea is one
of the stupidest things you can ever do
invest your heart your time your energy
your hustle to start making some money
and then as you make it you put it back
into the business to build it up and
grow so I'm glad you have nothing in
your bank account this is the greatest
lesson of all time it's gonna force you
to be creative it's gonna force you to
be resourceful people who have all the
money in the world they very rarely win
the kids the people who have all this
money they very rarely win because they
don't know how to be resourceful where
everybody who you look up to and respect
every single entrepreneur who's on your
list make a list of your top 5
successful entrepreneurs look at who
they are look at their story they
started with less than what you already
have right now and they won because they
were resourceful because they weren't
complaining about money about the lack
of money that they have and one of my
favorite quotes is Steve Wozniak who
said instead of thinking about the
resources you don't have the money that
you don't have start thinking about what
you can do with what you do have and I
think that's entrepreneurship in a
nutshell
if you're focused on the money you don't
have there in the education you don't
have that the parents that you don't
have the you know connections you don't
have you lost you lost your mindset is
you have a losing mindset you've lost
before you even started you are more
powerful than you realize you have
resources all around you you just have
to be more resourceful and go clean
what's yours and when it's hard and when
you're struggling and when it's not
happening for you yet that's the best
because in that struggle you will grow
strong and when you climb up to the next
step on the staircase because of how
much you struggle to get there you're
gonna want to serve and reach down this
there to the step below you pull
somebody up help make their path easier
to guys is one o'clock I got to hop onto
another call half-hour session this week
because it is a busy busy busy Thursday
thank you for the love and listen I'm
giving you any energy today pour it into
your work pour it into your mission do
something today that you will be proud
of that you want to show your kids you
want to show your grandkids I'm gonna
pour that into my next interviews I want
my grandkids to watch the next
interviews that I'm about to do for rest
of the day that's the intention that I
bring to every piece of content
everything every single thing that I do
every day and I hope that you guys do it
today too
whatever is left however many hours are
left and today make you can't do
something you want to show your
grandkids thank you guys for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon